les minutes de vérité et on va parler de
cet as far as pris ton le directeur des
programmes de tf1 et ex directeur des
programmes de ses 8 a laissé entendre au
micro de france inter lundi dernier
qu'ils voulaient enterrer la hache de
guerre avec nous ça nous a fait bien
plaisir sachez voilà chez des petites
révélations à vous faire mais juste
avant regarder ara aprikian sur france
inter ou et cyril hanouna vous vous
parler parce que vous vous connaissez
très bien vous l'avez fait ça a été
votre poulain sur ces 8 à une époque ça
peut ça peut arriver et donc vous vous
parlez
bah ça peut arriver ça peut arriver bon
très bien les chapitres du ce que je
veux dire c'est que là on est à l'aube
d'une nouvelle année dont j'en profite
pour espérer que cette année sera sur de
meilleurs auspices la télévision doit
être un lieu de rassemblement
moi je m'inscris dans cette dimension là
dans partageons des ondes positives qui
est le slogan de tf1 donc là vous
envoyer des ondes positives sur cyril
hanouna et c'est important
alors c'est vrai car après que vraiment
on a eu de bons moments puisque voilà
vraiment je vous le dis je vous raconte
tout c'est vrai que quand il a voulu
monter c'est vite il m'appelait ont
promis me voilà c'est la première
personne que voilà qu'on que j'ai
rencontrés on s'est rencontrés on a on a
même élaboré un petit peu voilà la
chaîne ensemble on a vraiment faisait
tout ensemble
c'est la personne j'avais plus au
téléphone on se parle et 15 fois par
jour c'est vrai que même vous vous le
saviez on était tout le temps ensemble
voilà et c'est vrai qu'après les
relations une fois qu'il est parti sur
tf1 se sont dégradées regarder les feux
de l'amour c'est moi et tf1 tf1 et moi
ara et baba était inséparable tel fatto
et gilles kelly et ses platines ou
encore valérie et sa moustache baba
était prête à tout pour son art à arrah
prête à tout pour son beau baba même à
redécorer son bureau pour crier au monde
entier son amour pour les talents
tunisiens
mais un beau jour ara commet
l'irréparable il tombe dans les bras
d'un ex de babar pour baba son métro il
craque pour se faire pardonner
ara tente de revenir vers baba en
utilisant ses extraordinaires capacités
de transformation repoussé par le jimmy
fallon pakistanais arad décide alors de
partie tf1 alors haras et ma ba vont-ils
enfin se rabibocher ou bien bas va-t-il
préféré céder aux avances enflammée du
remplaçant dahra le joli frankie dunn
m'attend coeur baba donne moi ton coeur
babin
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que c'est c'est vrai
que c'est un feuilleton alors ça avait
commencé lorsque gilles penet vers sien
c'est bon gilles pélisson le patron de
tf1 donne une conférence privée vous le
savez à des étudiants auraient parlé de
plusieurs talk-shows et avait taclé tpm
paix et nous essaient de la voilà qui
était parti voilà sept cette guerre
voilà qui n'est pas vraiment une guerre
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
se réconcilier avec tf1 oui vous oui ou
non on va les régler
oui oui bien sûr il est il est grand
temps d'ailleurs d'abord parce que ce
sont des acteurs majeurs du paf et qu'on
est une émission de médias et que donc
on il faut qu'on puisse avoir des
relations avec elle qu'avec cette chaîne
qui soient des relations apaisées comme
on en a avec france télévisions ou m6
voilà tout simplement
alors ils interdisent toujours à leurs
animateurs de venir et ça c'est sait
depuis fort longtemps vous gilles verdez
vous dites non absolument pas et c'est
le seul point de désaccord que j'ai
parfois avec vous je trouve que vous
fâcher avec des gens et après vous
voulez vous réconcilier vrai mais
pourquoi se réconcilier allez soyez
comme vous avez toujours été plus menace
un combattant
c'est où c'est eux qui vous ont agressé
la stratégie pour faire jouer c'est
parce qu'ils ont faire vincent lagaf les
déclarations de karine ferri tout est
dirigé contre vous ne cédez pas cyril je
vous en fais une guerre la guerre ce
score vous réconcilier avec eux il
faudrait qu'il fasse un vrai geste par
exemple qui nous laisse camille combal
venir ici en invité
qui vous fasse un vrai signe c'est comme
un ex une fois qu'on est brouillé avec
pour laisser revenir on va pas prendre
qu'un bouquet de roses il va falloir
qu'ils galèrent un petit peu alors avec
les galères et sachez qu'ils m'ont
envoyé leurs voeux
voilà vous avez répondu ara aprikian
aussi je suis entrain de réponse que
j'ai répondu art africain on a voilà on
a échangé
voilà maintenant on va voir mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont fait beaucoup de choses
dans notre dos voilà je vous le dis ils
ont pas été tendre avec nous ni avec le
groupe
voilà donc là on est dans un groupe e ça
peut peut-être s'apaiser mais voilà
c'est vrai qu'en tout cas au ce on se
reparle
mais bon c'est vrai que l'histoire 5 à 7
avec arthur voilà qui voulait tuer tpp
il ya eu ensuite la sphère camille
combal qu'ils ont fait dans notre dos
mine de rien et on n'a jamais su - voilà
je vous dis moi j'ai jamais vu et j'ai
géré posséder comme j'aime camille sée
c'est mon petit frère et jamais il m'a
dit droit dans les yeux oui je pars sur
tf1 parce que tf1 lui en avais l'en
avait empêché donc elle sait jamais mais
que vous ne voulez pas la chaîne non à
la chaîne parce que là ils ne pouvaient
pas se mettre à acheter avec la chaîne
au sein et leur dire avant d'arriver
la chaîne a dit laura et lui a dit tu ne
dis pas à cyril donc forcément ils
pouvaient pas le dire dans la série que
jamais il m'a dit clairement oui je vais
vers dents sur le faire dans cet état et
j'aurais été vrai je vous le dis sur une
ouïe très heureuse pour lui maintenant
géraldine oui mais sauf que vous seriez
vous êtes un homme fort vous n'êtes pas
une victime d'avoir tpp marche très très
bien et cartonne comme jamais même si on
a eu plein plein de coups dans le dos
derrière et devant et de tous les côtés
et donc moi je trouve que vous êtes au
contraire gilles un pacificateur
quand il ya un problème avec les gilet
jaune ben syrie il cherche à renouer le
dialogue est allé gilet jaune d'un côté
et ceux qui sont contre et qui s'y
opposent donc au contraire il faut
renouer le dialogue il faut tendre la
main
dans ces cas là il est médiateur alors
que là il est victime mais il n'est pas
visé
on va essayer d'apprécier ça je pourrais
avoir vite juste l'avis des
téléspectateurs parce qu'on va pas on va
passer à luc besson
oui à 71% non à 29% c'est un petit peu
voilà voilà ce qui se dit sur